it's Monday [__] get it together
your sloughs your snooze you lose on a
Monday I'm saying pilot to Bombardier
[__] you dare enter this [__]
house the reefer is on [__] fire
today you understand
are you kidding me or what May first
[__] the rent is due
you [__] sitting there on mama find
out from the weekend but who gives a
[__] jack
it's Monday [__] you snooze you lose
he who hesitates masturbate
today's the day Ruby's all hungover did
you go see the Billy Joel concert I
don't give a [__] jack I woke up this
morning with two lives in my pocket and
some [__] Vaseline to [__] gag a
[__] you understand me Wade
[__] around today Church 8 o'clock
tonight I got [__] hittin those tests
at [__] 11:00 I got a media jujitsu
we're going deep into the murky waters
today is your lucky day
with the three [__] understand me
Lewis
look at this [__] we got Neptune Oh Jean
we got perennial Luigi and we got
Holocaust oh gee this is the shift in
the one-eyed Jew he says when you smoke
it to put scotch tape on your eyes from
letting you I pop out you understand me
that's the type of reefer we're smoking
here with the jungle of [__] debt aka
the Garden of Good and Evil
now Joey what's with the [__] chitter
chatter I can't pick it down I came to
get down I can't to get down I came to
get down all right let's get [__] down
[__]
let's open up a little dose of perennial
first it's the mount this one the batch
just to get the part and don't get me
wrong this perennial put you in [__]
Mars you understand you don't need no
[__] satellites you don't need to
hang out with Russians to see the [__]
you're gonna see when you smoke this
[__] brilliant
understand me
oh it's Monday and the Koreans lit
another [__] dud you know these these
[__] North Koreans they should call
him Johnny Duds where the [__] do they
get their fireworks from everybody knows
you gotta go to the Chiney but they
can't go to the Chinese that's why they
keep spitting out [__] duds you
understand me you gotta go to the
Chinese you want a firecracker you want
to [__] get across you gotta go to
the Chinese get doctor hold they pulled
them off United he's ready to [__]
testify he don't give a [__] jack he
collected last week on a undisclosed
amount that Chinese guy is getting his
dick sucked and his balls licked right
now as we speak about a [__] plane
and now they can't grow them off now
they got a real [__] problem every
Chinese guys gonna get on a United
flight and [__] slow chopsticks and
the whole [__] thing but it'll give
us a [__] it's me and you on a Monday
morning here ready to [__] get down
you understand me
looking dapper as ever my folks are dead
there's be no you understand we got a
podcast and I ate a clock and guess what
I got another podcast Wednesday and
guess what I'm in [__] Utah hanging
out with Mormons all week and teaching
these [__] how to spark
speaking of sparking
a [__] the bases are loaded there's two
outs you know you're up at bat what do
you do you gonna sit there where you
gonna dig deep into the nut sack of debt
and let these [__] know where
you came from you understand
enough with the perennial let's do a
little bit of this [__] Neptune og
we'll save the Holocaust og for later
young saying that some people come home
and you want to bug the [__] oh this
[__] here
this [__] is weakened through [__]
Neptune this is Neptune oh gee do I have
to tell you you could take that [__]
satellite and all that [__] let's say
let's get one of those things that zooms
around get the [__] out of here
why zoom around when you could zoom
around on your [__] own you know
saying
ah the sun's shining the birds are
chirping it's a perfect day to go out
there and let these [__] know
what you're all about and let's
understand you have to impose your
[__] will on these
[__] who gives a [__] what they
came to listen to it's what I'm telling
you you know I'm saying [__] it that's
the state of mind if you don't have that
type of state of mind you're gonna hang
out at Starbucks with your friends
hahaha
did you see the impersonation of Alec
Baldwin of Trump oh my god it was so it
was so spot-on get the [__] out of here
you [__] Momo's while you're watching
Santa live somebody's [__] your chick
up the airs having a good time yeah I'm
saying I mean why you wanna he's hers
personation shot what the [__] is wrong
with America get it together here
impersonation I'm the real [__] deal
nobody impersonates flavor you know why
cuz we talk for my nutsack when you're
talking mean nutsack ain't nobody can
[__] do what you do you follow me
Oh killing [__] with this
reefer tight and there you are
I don't know what I'm gonna do with my
life Motech turned me down who gives a
[__] oh there's a [__] get out there
start y'all [__] car lot start
painting cars your way is this [__]
eventually they'll go you're [__]
genius you follow me cuz you don't give
a [__] that's the main thing about a
Monday that sets the new difference from
the rest of these [__] mama Lucy
ready you don't give a [__] you're a
scary mother [__] when you don't give a
[__] I don't give a [__] you could say
no to me you could kick me stab me
that's what life is about
so suck my dick it's [__] Monday
mother [__] I'm coming out the box
like a [__] forget like that bombed
trunk drop on the [__] and the
[__] tunnels over there that's how
coming from the heaviest [__] bomb
ever that's me [__] off that
[__] bomb with a big big personality
I'm Sam
and now it's time for la pierre de la
resistance this is weed from the
one-eyed Jew he's bringing it over from
[__] Israel this is that crap my god
wait I'm saying he smoked too bold for
this you think he got karate-chop for
the next four [__] times nobody shows
up with Krav Maga we'd like the Joey
this is [__] Holocaust oh gee forget
about it forget about it looking to see
the devil right now so if I start
blacking out you start hearing yells and
screams or catching [__] at
eight o'clock on the punch that's
tonight cuz I love you I miss you I'm
saying I'm happy I'm here with you
[__] too late you know nobody
can stop get to that man
it's all in your [__] head nobody can
[__] stop you your 10th are you
you have to strength attend [__] car
beeps Tulane they can't [__] stop
except when it comes to [__] putting
down a sandwich you got the strength of
10 collar Biebs today go out there do
your tank here we go Holocaust Oh Jean
oh my god
it's Monday [__] never forget
that Monday's is your step up if you
fail on Monday well you got Tuesday but
you never want to fail on Monday you
want to come out the box strong and
position yourself for that we can let
these [__] know you're there
that's it it's that simple you're there
I'm here top notch I loud then like
Latinos say when you meet them they tell
you their name cuz I'm Tonioli abaya you
need for me the helicopter over [__]
Cuba let's [__] do it
anyway this Holocaust og ain't no joking
[__] I starting to twitch on the inside
that's when you know you got [__]
problems
oh yeah so don't forget me Salt Lake
City Friday and Saturday for shows only
don't [__] around then the final meeting
at Detroit and Milwaukee Detroit sold
out we had the show is sold out
Milwaukee we got about a hundred tickets
I don't [__] around
I don't like say next week no joke miss
down I don't know what to do go [__]
yourself
get it right now and put it away now so
we have a good time next Friday night
next Friday night but the [__] 12th
all right that's it and that's that you
guys you're on your own it's time for
you to [__] justify your existence
get out there
it's [__] Monday don't take no [__]
from nobody I'll see you [__]
eight o'clock tonight
hey don't [__] with me or you get the
drink I might them more wrong go away
bye
okay Lucy kettle Bing oh wow that means
I gotta suck it [__] hard today cuz
you're a bad [__] see you guys
later stay black have a good day